maybe a question about elon musk
um even more than jeff bezos
he has a very kind of
ambitious vision
of um this
project that we're on as a species yeah
of becoming a multiplanatarian species
and becoming that quickly
yeah as soon as possible landing on mars
colonizing mars what do you think of
that project
there's two questions to ask first the
question is what
what do you think about the project of
colonizing mars
and second
what do you think
about a human being
who is so
unapologetically
ambitious at achieving the impossible at
what a lot of people would say is
impossible i think that colonizing mars
is the kind of
of goal that's uh it's easily
stated
it's
it's catchy it's it's it's the kind of
thing that
that can inspire people to get involved
in a way that some other programs might
not
um so i think it's well chosen in that
way
i have technical questions
about um
you know there's there's a problem of
perchlorates uh on the surface of mars
this that's going to be big trouble
um
and there's there's radiation so and
this is known i'm
uh but um what about business questions
do you think because you mentioned sort
of uh
going outside of the solar system would
would best be done for religious reasons
what about colonizing mars
can you spin it into a business
proposition it's hard to
think of a resource that's on mars that
could be brought back here
cheaply enough to compete
with um
with stuff we could just dig out of the
ground here or grow here
so i don't know if there is a business
plan for that or if it's just strictly
we're going to go there
and and see what happens
you know
maybe again we need communism to kind of
yeah to get us going to give us a reason
a little bit of the competition well
there's plenty of people who are
sufficiently excited by
the colonized mars vision that they're
willing to to just go all in on it
even if there's not a business
plan behind it
so
so i think it's well chosen it's just uh
um
[Music]
i i think it's probably the only um
the only approach to take um
again a lot of the when when white
people came to this continent and and
started colonizing it
you know
uh
there was not a lot of coherent planning
like what what plans they did have
turned out to be terrible plans um
you know trying to come up with plans
that extend decades into the future is
uh is a waste of time
to do it for the kind of
the like unexplainable love of the
unknown like like
the the uh the journey towards
exploring the unknown yeah and just kind
of keep going yeah
well you saw it with shatner and his
uh reaction to the the flight uh
yesterday
um
he uh
for him that trip was
more than worth it just for these
intangible reasons
what did you say i haven't watched the
video yet he was trying to express the
the talking a lot about the moment where
suddenly you kind of
rise above the the thin blue blanket of
uh
of the atmosphere and and you're up into
the the blackness um and uh
that had a huge
impact on him so he was kind of uh i
wouldn't say groping for words because
he was pretty eloquent but
he was trying to express his feelings
about that um
in a way that is pretty pretty gripping
to watch
so
you've worked on this kind of stuff we
can go back to 10 years ago you wrote an
essay
called innovation starvation you worked
on this kind of idea
since then
kind of looking at
maybe a little bit cynically about
our age today and our unwillingness to
take on big risky projects
so in the face of that what do you think
of people like elon musk
because to me people like that
are inspiring and gives you hope in the
face of a more kind of um
pessimistic perspective
of our age
yeah well he's clearly willing to tackle
um
[Music]
big ambitious uh projects uh without a
lot of um
kind of soul searching or uh or were
trying to make up his mind right he's
just like
um just go and do it let's dig tunnels
under cities go you know let's uh um
step one make a joke about it on twitter
step two actually do it yeah yeah
yeah
and uh i mean things have slowed down uh
quite our ability to um
to build things uh
uh
at pace um is is a lot less than it was
and there's there's reasons for that you
know we're more concerned with safety
and
environmental impacts than um than
people were when they were building
some of the great publix works projects
of the mid
20th century
but even we're at the point now where
even just maintaining the stuff that
we've got is such a huge
project
that we need to put big resources into
it and and good minds into it um or else
we're going to be
we're going to be losing
things that we
take for granted
you